[Music]
hi everyone well it's really nice to be
here
how's it how's your day being gone great
okay so hopefully this one is not too
boring to to be you know a talk at this
time of the day cuz I'm pretty sure you
had I have seen a lot of talks already
but just briefly introducing myself for
those who don't know me my name is Evan
you my twitter handle is Yahoo she was
just my Chinese name I'm an independent
open source developer since 2016 so that
is to say I've been working just on open
source independently for three years now
and I work primarily on vue.js how many
of you actually use it
OOP all right great
so it started as a side project when t13
and I've been working on a full time
since 2016 and over the years of working
on frameworks right I've learned a lot
of stuff and that kind of also given me
a lot of perspective on the internal
designs some of the trade-offs decisions
on that people make when it comes to
building frameworks right how many of
you remember the days backing like 2013
when there's probably a new JavaScript
framework coming out every single day to
do NBC has a list of like 4050
frameworks all building the same thing
and view kind of started around their
time where I was just looking at some of
these existing solutions and trying to
figure out what would I do if I were to
build something like this okay but
obviously my ideas around what should be
done has evolved over time and change a
lot but today I'm going to be talking
about some of these findings
specifically front-end framework design
I bet a lot of you have been using a
framework even if you're not using view
probably use react angular or some other
framework it's hard to imagine building
a complex front-end application without
something of that sort today right you
can probably still build things with
vanilla JavaScript but we know it's
gonna take a bit more time however at
the same time like because of all these
frameworks I guess most of you are also
kind of tired of all these framework
comparisons right this is how I look
like whenever I see yet another
framework comparison article pop-up a
medium like the the best seven new
frameworks to using 2019 I just like not
because you know not because I built
view and I want people to use it or I
don't want to see people hating on it
right but because most of the time these
articles just focus on things like
github stars or NPM download counts or
Stack Overflow questions these stats
that you can just easily find anywhere
anybody can just google them up right
but these stats while still kind of
useful to a certain extent maybe for
marketers right but if you're trying to
make a technical decision and you're
trying to compete some of these
relatively mature technologies these
numbers are less less less and less
relevant above a certain threshold right
like most of these you know what we use
in production today probably have over
10,000 stars on github right above that
threshold like really does it really
matter like how many stars like several
thousand stars this library has got it
doesn't really matter that much what you
should probably care more about is some
of the internal technical decisions like
what actually defers these frameworks so
before we dig into that take a step back
and think about like all the common
goals of these frameworks we we all are
working towards the same goal
all these framework authors are trying
to provide you with something that
helped you to build web apps as
efficiently as possible then why do we
have all these different competing ideas
and is a good thing or is it bad thing
right so so wide
we have so many different framers each
with a decent sizable following right
because I believe like reactive you each
have each have more than half a million
users so what is that I think the the
source the the reason is that there
isn't a single good versus bad spectrum
for frameworks right people tend to ask
questions like which framework is better
like just stop asking that right because
it's not that simple to say framework a
is better than framework B we know that
software design is about trade-offs so
our front-end framework design there are
so many trade-offs in fact especially in
the web world right because the web is
the platform with probably the most
diverse set of use cases we we build all
kinds of crazy stuff on the web from the
simplest page possible to the most
complex application you use every day
right so to accommodate to all these use
cases framers have to make trade-offs
not just on a single spectrum and they
have to we have to make trade-offs on
multiple spectrums a lot of different
areas right so and today I'm sure I'm
going to be talking about some of these
hopefully giving you some insight on
like what to look look at but due to the
time constraint I won't be able to
digging like to all of these possible
dimensions so I'll focus on a few of
them scope so this is essentially how
much the framework is trying to do for
you and then the render mechanism how
does the framework when you use in
framework how do you express your views
structure and how does the framework
handles your code how does it actually
render stuff to the page and then
there's the state mechanism mutable
versus immutable dirty-checking versus
dependency tracking reactivity versus
simulated reactivity actually I won't
have time to dig into this one maybe
this will be another talk at a later
time
so I dig right go riding to scope how
much a framework is trying to do for you
so let's put it on a spectrum
and you'll have one end where the
framework or the library is doing
intentionally smaller things where on
the other end we have more monolithic
things like frameworks I try to provide
as many features as possible
excuse me so some of the iconic examples
probably most people know about right
react kind of nicely falls onto the the
end of libraries primitives and angular
falls on the side of frameworks
providing you with a lot of the
abstractions right so rarely exemplifies
the philosophy where the library is
focused on providing a very fundamental
model for thinking about UI it tries to
focus on providing you with these
lower-level
good primitives on which you can build
your own abstractions with the scope is
intentionally small so when so that's
why also why riyadh has a very very
active ecosystem right so along with the
ecosystem react is like the bazaar where
the system is sort of organically built
bottom-up by the community around the
core model the riad has established on
the other end so angular and alongside
is some of the other frameworks like
ember aralia are more like the cathedral
right they're designed top-down where
most of the conceivable problems are you
that the users will probably run to has
been sort of considered during the
design process form validation
animations most of the common things you
will encounter during daily development
the framework tries to provide a
solution for you and in order to do that
the the framework has to be designed in
a way that is very top-down we have to
think about everything how how
everything works together fit together
from day one right so and and this this
scope is intentionally big because the
goal of the such a design is so that
when you are trying to solve a problem
you will be able to find the solution
within the framework now we call this
small scope versus big scope and it's
not to say not necessarily about good or
bad again I want to emphasize
so some pros of the small scope is there
are fewer concepts to get started with
and there's more flexibility so there's
mortgage demand opportunities right
because the framework the library is
only providing with some really
low-level primitives so you have a
component model you have some props you
can pass props to it and then you can
return some virtual Dom tree that's
pretty much it that's about that's
pretty much it about react right but on
top of that you can build arbitrary
complex systems so react has a very very
active ecosystem people see that they
have these very flexible tools and you
know they just run wild with their
creativity so there are a lot of great
ideas coming out of the react react
community and in addition being
intentionally small in scope also allows
the team to have a smaller maintenance
surface so that they can focus on the
things that they believe that matters
all right so the team can focus on
exploring new ideas which is why react
can spend such a long time working on
things like concurrent mode suspense we
add hooks and all these interesting
stuff they've been cranking out in the
past few weeks or months right they've
actually been working on it for a few
years already so but this is because you
know they have a small scope so they can
focus on these things so there are some
cons of small scope obviously so first
is there's more plumbing work needed
when solving inherently complex problem
with simple concepts so there was a talk
that I really liked by guy Steele called
a growing a language so during the talk
guy set himself a rule so he during that
talk he has to he can only use single
syllable words and if you want to use
any words that's has like more than one
syllables he has to define it first with
single syllable words right so he he is
given a very limited list of primitive
stuff to to to be able to construct more
complex ideas with so you can imagine
how that talk went right so every before
he speaks every sentence he has to like
take out a few slides and
find a bunch of words before he can
proceed and that's kind of like building
a really complex production grade app
with very very low level primitives you
have to build a lot of Astra
abstractions to make yourself more
efficient along the way now because of
that patterns naturally emerge over time
right when we say react is really simple
to get started with we're kind of
ignoring the fact that you sort of more
or less have to learn Redux before you
can consider yourself in real react
developer and then you have to know
about things like higher order
components or prot render props and then
now you have to learn hooks and the many
different ways of using CSS MJS right so
although these patterns emerge over time
and they kind of become semi required
right if you don't know about these you
really can call yourself a developer and
oftentimes these things are not
officially documented if you go to the
react website they're not going to tell
you which CSS and J's solution to use
you have to do your own research and
learn it right so that's kind of the
cause of of having a really really you
know user land dominated system now the
ecosystem can be moving too fast and can
lead to fragmentation and constant churn
and I believe anyone who's been
following along in the early days of the
flux sort of every day there's a new
flux implementation and then later on
every day there's a new CSS JS
implementation right it's good and at
the same time the good is there are
always these new ideas coming out and
we're trying to figure out what is
actually the best way to do it the the
bad thing is for people who are just
trying to follow along and get something
built you have this constant FOMO right
you're always in the fear of missing out
on the next best thing so we're done
with the small scope cons and let's talk
about the pros of you know being large
in scope right the most obvious
advantage is most common problems can be
solved with building abstractions so if
you're just trying to get something
built
I just need a router I need some
animation I need to fetch some data with
an HTTP client right framework like
angular provides everything you need to
get that out of the door so you don't
actually have to look elsewhere you just
read the documentation use the framework
and you can get things done centralized
design process ensures consistent and
coherent ecosystem right so you don't
have to shop for different solutions
when you're running into a specific
problem you just look at the framework
see what the framework tells you to do
right most likely it has an opinion on
it so you don't have to go digging to
ten different competing solutions and
figure out which one fits your use case
best now the cons of being large in
scope is there is a higher upfront
learning barrier in order to get the
pixel onto the screen the the hoops you
have to jump through to get there this
can be a big deterrent for beginners for
people without proper or I wouldn't say
proper people without prior experience
in dealing with back-end languages like
if you've never used Java or C sharp
you've only learned HTML CSS and
JavaScript reading the angular
documentation is probably a pretty you
know humbling experience I would say it
is still for me now it can be inflexible
if built in solution doesn't fit the use
case right sometimes you might just feel
like I wish I could do it the other way
but I don't have the option to swap it
out and finally a framework that is
large in scope and here Allah makes
introducing fundamental new ideas much
more costly because there are so many
associated pieces that needs to work
consistently together and when you try
to change a fundamental idea it affects
every component in your system so making
changes is just a much harder thing
whereas if you think about in the
ecosystem because the core team is not
really responsible for a lot of these
solutions in the wild when you say
introduced hooks which made Redux morale
redundant right it's not a really a
problem so there's that okay so now this
is where view kind of falls on but
before we dig into what view is doing I
want to emphasize like this is not about
like how view is better than both of
these right because being in the middle
doesn't necessarily indicate it's the
best if you stretch this spectrum like
long enough you zoom out line of you'll
see like they aren't actually all in
kind of in the optimal zone already so
it's just like we slightly defer on
where we think that the optimal point is
so each choice also kind of fits the
needs of different groups of users right
it's not like one thing that can fit all
so what I call the way views take view
takes on the scope problem is you
probably know the tagline view is called
we call it view the progressive
framework so being progressive in scope
means the framework uses a layer design
that allows features to be opted in in a
progressive manner that is to say if you
don't need routing if you don't need
state management if you don't need a
build step even right you can use view
without any of those you're just pulling
view jeaious onto your page and you can
instantly start working on something the
the learning barrier of jumping from
beginner to getting a pixel on the
screen is it's shortened by removing
anything that could be in your way on
your first on your first minute of
learning so this is the the low entry
learning barrier is really important for
us because one of the mission of view is
to allow more people to getting to web
development to allow people to to learn
this and to focus on building things
instead of instead of learning about a
lot of concepts that might not be
necessary for your current use case
right so but we still have documented
solutions for these current problems
like so as your use case gets more
complicated as you're building something
more complex you realize okay I need
do need a router so you're looking to
the documentation you see okay if you
actually does provider routers which I
can use right but at the same time the
router is not a required piece and you
can actually implement your own if you
want to because you see how views router
is built and is cleanly the cup hold
from the core implementation so you kind
of realize that you can build your own
solution too if you want to so it's not
perfect because we being in the middle
actually means we are sharing the cons
of both sides so first although we are
making the adoption incremental we are
still responsible for maintaining all
these things right so we share the same
maintenance surface problem of big scope
we want to change something
fundamentally we have to make sure the
whole ecosystem moves along with it
right so this maintenance burden is
almost the same with big scope and at
the same time because we do provide
these pre these pre-built solutions
right our ecosystem probably will be not
as diverse as say react the small scope
system because small scope is inherently
like leaving the problem to the to the
community whereas in our case a lot of
users will be happy with our solutions
and it probably won't spend time on
trying to figure out their own solutions
so that is the scope problem so
hopefully you can kind of you now have
an idea of where sort of this is what I
think is the most fundamental difference
between reiax view and angular and this
is the this exact positioning is where
it defines our different user bases so
and I think a lot of times we're making
intentional decisions in terms of where
we extend and we as framework designers
we know that we are attacking different
sectors and I think that's a good thing
because different developers need
different solutions and having major
framers covering the whole spectrum
ensures everyone gets what they want
ok so now let's talk about rendering
mechanism ie
how a framework
allows you to express your UI structure
and how it renders stuff and primarily
this will be this is actually a pretty
complex practice spectrum in itself it's
not just a single thing so it's like a
multi dimension in itself but let's
briefly simplify it and think of it as
JSX
versus templates that is dynamic render
functions versus static string-based
compliation based view expressions and
then there's expressiveness versus raw
performance then there is run time
scheduling versus ahead of time
optimizations some people have really
strong opinions on this but but I
personally feel that they are more alike
inherently they're just different
strategies of expressing the same
underlying idea so it's more about the
technical trade-offs right so on the
Left the spectrum obviously JSX react
and all the react like libraries that
use some sort of virtual Tom like
pre-act stencil infernal right and then
on the other side template based
solutions so I'll talk about Vee later
but the more the more representative
template based solutions spelt and then
there's ember so that logo is actually
glamorous logo so glimmer is the
rendering engine inside ember and then
angular as well so these are primarily
template based they compile template
into relatively lower level instructions
to render stuff now let's talk about the
pros of the JSX and virtual Dom approach
right the most important reason people
like JSX or virtual Dom is they have the
full expressiveness of JavaScript you're
not confined to a arbitrary syntax you
have a language at your disposal you can
its store incomplete you can pretty much
do anything you want right you're not so
you can build arbitary
complex logic you know components and
it's really powerful and liberating
right a lot of people like react for
that for this particular reason and it
also allows you to treat the view as
data when you render a component it
always returns something it returns the
tree the the virtual Dom tree that
represents the current state of your
component and this data can be used for
a lot of interesting purposes it gives
you useful and possibility to build say
testing solutions you can take snapshots
based on the virtual Dom you can render
it to alternative targets people have
been doing things like rendering it to
terminals
PDF canvas WebGL anything you can think
of that you can render to write because
the view is data and you can do anything
with data now the cause of virtual Dom
is that it is actually inherently
expensive all right think about it right
when we at first came out a lot of
people are like isn't this going to be
slow and reacts answer is yes we are
it's slow but it's fast enough right but
still like from a pure technical process
to back perspective you're doing a lot
of unnecessary work think about this
simple template where the amount of work
needed to just update that single
message binding in there all right we
have to walk through the whole virtual
Dom tree and diff diff diff diff diff
you just have to recursively keep going
down until somehow you update this in
this process so standard virtual Dom
different cost is relative to the total
size of your view rather than the number
of nodes that may change right even if
you only have one node that may change
the virtual Dom different algorithm
doesn't know the reason is the dynamic
nature of render functions makes it hard
to optimize for right by dynamic I mean
you can write code like this right you
can just use a for loop to construct a
Chaudron array and then give it to your
parent node and God knows what you other
things you can do to say you can create
this parent no first then like many then
mutate its children you can
additional elements into it right the
compiler won't be able to cover all the
possible edge cases you can do with
JavaScript because JavaScript is simply
too dynamic there are a lot of attempts
in the space and but inherently it's
just like it's hard to provide safe
optimizations in this way right because
there isn't simply enough assumptions
you can make the more assumptions you
can make about the user intention the
easier it is to optimize the code and
with JavaScript it's just really really
hard
now finally we a solution to this
problem is to instead of focusing on
making virtual DOM itself faster how
about making perceived performance
better so it introduces run time
scheduling concurrent smote time slicing
but this having this runtime solution
having this whole fiber kind of like
almost managing your own stack trait
I'm almost managing our own stack like
entering and exiting rendering all the
stuff requires a heavy runtime right so
this means whenever you load react you
have to load all the code that is
necessary for handling all these complex
runtime scheduling stuff that's like
several 20 30 KB of JavaScript right and
that in turn also makes your initial
loading suffer a little bit and on the
other hand if you are compiling
rendering code from a template usually
it can produce far more direct render
instructions with better raw performance
the reason being that the template is by
definition a very very constraining
language you can only write template a
certain way for example when you write
code like this we can instantly tell
that there's no way the order of these
pecan chain ever change there's no way
this ID can ever change there's no way
this class can ever change the only
thing that can change is this so being
static and very restrictive actually
allows the compiler to make a more
assumptions about your intention and
that gives it more room to perform
optimizations
think about what spell does when it
compiles your code right
everything else is static but only name
could possibly change so this P is the
update function in Kapaa wipeout code
and the only thing it does is change
whether name has changed and then
updated if it has changed so compare
this to all the things a virtual Dom
different algorithm tries to do the
difference is just orders of magnitude
faster right so depending on strategy
template compilation or in general
compilation based approach can also
result in much lighter runtime baseline
size because it doesn't need all the
complex runtime scheduling to trying to
make things look faster because it's
already fast right so spouts can produce
extremely lightweight output without
having to require a heavy heavy baseline
runtime to accommodate to all the
possible runtime behavior now the cause
of template compilation is obviously you
are constrained by the template syntax
you lose the expressiveness of
JavaScript so when you are trying to
build a really complex component you'll
feel like oh I wish I can do this in the
template but the compiler does not
support it right you're out of luck
there's no escape hatch if you go the
full compilation route because the low
the more lower level the the compiled
output is the less likely you'll be able
to actually hook into it and do your
custom operations there it's like a no
pay compiler that's you won't be able to
like digging to assembly with see why
that that's just you know the way it is
now it's as if you won't be able to
debug your assembly code with C so now
light or runtime lighter base baseline
runtime we also come at the cost of more
verbose output per template right
because you're trying to when you're
trying to produce code as that executes
as efficiently as possible
sometimes you would have to encode more
information in the output directly for
example the code that spouts produces
actually imperative Lee creates all the
elements lineman lying insert them one
by one and they have a separate function
for updating them right in comparison a
virtual down based result you would have
to just have one line and that's just a
single expression that returns the
virtual down structure so real time
compilation there's a there's a runtime
compilation cost if you compile on the
fly right so most likely for production
use cases you would require users to
compile beforehand so that place is a
hard requirement on a build step which
is something you know is just inevitable
you either compile on the fly or pre
build which then involves all the
node.js tool chains which we are more or
less used to now but still if you can
avoid it it would be really nice for
people when people are getting started
okay so again view kind of falls in the
middle again I want to emphasize this
not saying view is the best but the
unique thing about views rendering
mechanism is we have both virtual DOM
and template compilation if you actually
compose templates into virtual Dom under
under the hood so we kind of get the
best of both worlds we have performance
right the compilation step produces
especially optimized we don't render
function I'll talk about this in a bit
in a bit of more details later right in
to point X we actually haven't fully
exploited this this opportunity the
current view to point X virtual Dom
performance is probably just average
virtual Dom typical virtual Dom
performance all right but I'll talk a
bit about what we're doing in 3.0 to
make this much much faster
and then there's expressiveness you can
actually skip the template layer you can
drop down into render functions and
directly leverage javascript to to
perform arbitrarily complex logic so
this gives you an escape hatch when you
feel you're constrained by templates
right now
that the downside is right although we
can be really really fast we're not we
can probably never be as fast as they
felt because spell just it's the it's
the vanilla it's kind of its output is
pretty much vanilla JavaScript whereas
in order to be compatible with
handwritten render functions view still
has to maintain a virtual Dom so that
constants inevitable and on the other
hand it kind of also creates a split
between like which one should I use
problem so a lot of users although they
can actually use render functions
they're probably just never use it
so now let's stick it into what we're
doing through file to make views
template compile to virtual Dom run
faster than normal virtual Dom this is
what we already talked about right this
template there's only one node that
would change the ideal update path is
just if this message string directly
note structure is static and never
changes there's only one dynamic node so
if we consider this template it's a very
very simple case it becomes a bit more
complicated when you have things like VF
which is what we call a structural
directive in JSX this is pretty much
equivalent of a ternary based on a
condition you return different branches
right now this creates a dynamic node
structure because the node may be there
or may not be there so to deal with this
a naive virtual Dom different algorithm
would have to just assume the node list
has changed and try to diff the two
children arrays but if we try to split
it apart and see the if separates of
templating to two nested blocks the
outer block if we consider the V if
itself as a node then the outer block
has a static node content node structure
inside the VF block it also is static so
we have now we we have to static blocks
we're within each block you will have no
need to diff any order node order
changes the only thing you need is a
flat array of the things that could
possibly
change inside this block similarly 4v
for every v4 iteration we consider it a
static block right block so if you have
more like a V if inside v4 you just spit
split further into nested blocks so we
end up with something I call a block
tree this is just a play on something we
know but the block tree is a nested
block blocks right because each block
within each block you have a completely
static node structure so there's no need
for any sort of like recursively going
down and try to diff to children lists
within each block you just have one
single flat array of the nodes that
could possibly change on top of this we
also have additional organization hints
on for example if a node has only a
dynamic class binding we have a fast
path for that you just directly set the
class and you can go ahead you don't
have to diff the props if you don't want
to if you don't you don't have to right
so the before and after is pretty
obvious for the same for the same
template previously we had to do all the
full algorithm for different everything
and afterwards we just do a single flat
there it will be a single array
containing just this node with a dynamic
text and the only thing you need to do
is compare the TEC whether the text has
changed so we did a brief benchmark with
this is a list of 1000 v4 iterations
within each block you have around 12 Dom
nodes that is a total of 12,000
downloads within each iteration you have
for dynamic bindings some classes some
text so that is 4000 dynamic bindings on
the page and we update all of these
bindings and we do 100 runs take the
average current 2.6 per update is 36
milliseconds in current 3.0 prototype
with the new compliation strategy is
takes only around 5.4 Millicent
so that is more than six times faster in
this benchmark that Thanks so note in
this benchmark alone right is probably
your real app probably will have a
different number but you know more or
less it's going to be a lot faster and
that's the that's the baseline so in
then state mechanism I probably don't
have time to really dig into this so
that will be another talk but to wrap up
where is the perfect balance point we
are trying to when you're trying to
design a framework right the question
should be probably be rephrased does a
perfect balance even exist and is it is
a single perfect balance point even
optimal for jaidev's as a whole right
because like all of us are trying to
optimize different things where you're
building something specific for example
like for spelt right its advantages its
it can produce extremely lightweight
code when you're building something
small and it's also extremely fast he's
a lot very very little memory so it can
be used on like even embedded devices
but if you're targeting use cases where
you know you probably have a more
complex use case you have more
components you want the expressiveness
of JavaScript but you also want a bit
more performance from the templates you
can probably go with view and then if
you don't you know really care about
that much about extreme performance but
you're like I like react ecosystem you
can go with react right there's all
these options you can you can pick so I
think it's nice that the framework
landscape is like a multi-dimensional
space with multiple ever moving entities
like think of each framework as an
entity trying to look for the balance
point it believes is the best we're all
trying to figure out what's the best way
to do things and there will be multiple
of us always right so as developers you
kind of you're like floating around in
between these entities like you're
you're dragged towards one of them by
their gravity
and sometimes you may just you know
switch around you hop around and try to
figure out which one is best for you I
think that's a that's a good thing right
but but as a user right trying to
navigate this multi-dimensional space
can be daunting right but if you want to
pick up the framework properly the hard
way then you have to understand some of
these internal trade-offs the the
frameworks I'm making right you have to
be aware of which direction this
framework is heading towards and does
whether it aligns with which you are
prioritizing in the thing you are trying
to build
so hopefully this talk has shed some
light on that topic and could help you
when you are trying to pick between
frameworks in the future or tell other
people how they should pick a framework
thank you
[Applause]